[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
john wertheim
has the book the summer of 1984 in the
90 days that changed sports and culture
forever now available online wherever
books are sold
john i'm 100 pages in a little over 100
pages in i got to the point where
you mentioned me when i was at cnn
and i was okay with it but you know you
threw in the word
sticky and i don't know if that's in a
good way or bad way john can you can you
help because it's ruined it's basically
ruined my uh my night last night
oh come on it was the in the best
possible sense
the uh the nba has a new commissioner
a guy named david stern in 1984 and he's
an internal candidate and is so little
known that
an ascending broadcast personality you
didn't
you didn't say ascending broadcaster
dashingly hamstrings you didn't even say
that
yeah you didn't say that i mean
they're serious i mean so so we'll tell
the story so uh
you you had a it was fun um
you asked people on the street if they
knew isaac stern
daniel stern or or david stern i believe
but i think the real point is like yeah
howard stern but
um i think the real point is people
forget that david stern was not this
celebrated commissioner when he took
over the job in 84 and uh
this little known lawyer quickly got to
work
there's a uh a great quote in here and
uh it's early in the book it says
history doesn't send out
in uh invitations in advance
uh apparently somebody else is calling
john right now
you only works for 60 minutes so wait
are you on assignment right now
john you uh you say that jokingly for
forgive uh forgive that crazy day
um you you have uh history doesn't send
out invitations in advance
uh i i love that line and you know going
back and reading all the things that
happened in 1984 i i don't know if there
was a point where you go
there is enough to be able to write a
book about this like
was there a certain number that you were
looking at to go if i get
to that then i can write this book once
we had eight no i mean the real
challenge
like so all this stuff happens in 84
right uh you've got the ascent of jordan
and he's sort of the spine of the book
imagine you're david stern and you've
got bird magic in a game seven
and then a few days after that you come
to new york for your first draft and oh
right it's
sam bowie elijah and jordan barkley uh
when you're in
among your top five picks but um i mean
the real so all the stuff happens as you
say and it's gretzky wins his first cup
and you've got the profitable olympics
and karate kid and
the real the real mystery to me was sort
of why was it just
coincidence or was there something that
really was going on in the culture that
was
elevating sports and making it such a
big deal in this this compressed period
of time
and the importance that music played in
writing this book because
you do mention there's springsteen and
prince on the cover
uh mtv was just getting big at that
moment uh so that intersection
how did you how did you try to weave
that in
what cable and espn was to sports that
summer
which was sort of like holy cow we've
got this force and we can get it anytime
we want and it's a new experience and by
the way there's going to be some real
money here
it was really similar to what mtv did to
music
and you know this was just as we went
from like oh there's a game of the week
to wow i can get this anytime i want
um 24 7 you could not only listen to
the artists that you loved on the radio
but you could see these little mini
movies that went with all the songs
uh is there a moment that stood out
because it's something that you didn't
realize
in the moment or maybe you had you you'd
forgotten about it
i it's that's a good question i mean i
think some of it was um
just how big an impact jordan had as
much as we know about jordan you know we
all know six rings we can all
do do our uh sort of the last dance uh
recitation but
i think people don't realize how much he
changed the model and the leverage of
talent and the athlete and this 550
grand whatever it was the bulls are
paying me that that's nice but i can
make a lot more money from a lot of
different places that hadn't really
happened
before him the other one i'm sure you've
probably heard the story but i
i didn't realize this whole victory tour
you know
michael jackson most popular man on the
planet his parents say this thriller
album's great but you got to make us
rich you got to make your brothers rich
they do a victory tour don king somehow
manages to insinuate himself as the
promoter but
the tour is bankrolled by the sullivan
family they collateralize sullivan
stadium
the tour is an absolute fiasco the
brothers hate each other
michael's bringing along emmanuel lewis
and brooke shields and the brothers
still talk to them and
it loses so much money that the sullivan
family sell the team
through a number of twists that ends up
with this gentleman uh named bob kraft
and you could
make a credible case i think the
patriots dynasty doesn't happen if
michael jackson doesn't do the stupid
victory tour there's so many
things that are connected here um i love
the martina nevatolova
uh stuff because people forget how brave
she was
when she defected and and really she was
part of the modern athlete
her and jordan at about that same time
mike had hired tim grover to be his
trainer
it was okay to lift weights martina said
it's okay
to to look like this to be in shape and
i
i thought that those were very
interesting uh parallels between those
two
an esteemed weekly sports publication
that will go unnamed
made fun of martini she used a super
computer to tech to check on the
statistical tendencies of her opponents
now we would saw that analytics and you
know she had i think i think the quote
was like
she had vines of gnarled veins crawling
up her arms
well gee she got herself in shape to
play a sport that's that's a crazy
thought
she had an entourage of people that
acted as a support team
um but she was way ahead of her time and
wasn't just uh
it wasn't just that she didn't get
credit for it she was mocked this was
like something you made fun of her for
for using a super computer and uh in
1984
she was basically playing moneyball with
tennis
he's john worth i'm the uh sports
illustrated executive editor
and of course the author of glory days
you can see him on 60 minutes it's the
summer of 1984 the 90 days that changed
sports and culture forever now available
online
wherever books are sold i was in the
early stages of my career
of course in an ascending career but i
was there to cover the usfl
and i went to those press conferences at
uh trump tower
where he'd have the big waterfall and
the escalator
and you know if it was doug flutie or
herschel walker i covered the usfl trial
like
these are all these these bring like i
get twitch i start to twitch a little
bit
when i think back to that what did you
find out about
trump then that maybe
would have braced you for us that this
is who
trump is now uh that is a great way to
put it he
give him this he's he's committed to the
role i mean you mentioned press
conference and escalators and trump
tower
and uh be sure use that playbook again
um no i mean you go back and part of it
jeff perlman wrote a great book about
trump and the usfl and there were some
great stories from 84 is sort of when he
became this national figure
and you read those stories and it's
amazing
to compare that to you know trump trump
plays fast and loose with the truth but
he sure has a certain magnetism
um there was a story that willy geist's
dad wrote an article and it said
something like
you know riding around with donald trump
is like you know riding around manhattan
with a motorcycle with no windshield
you get a lot of bugs in your teeth but
it sure is fun and
basically he is what he is and the same
uh sort of the same playbook he used
with the usfl
the same way there was a lot of
vagueness there was a lot of media i
mean
charlie steiner who is the sort of the
voice of the general tells the story
he said the players love trump because
after the game he'd go to the locker
room and he'd say you know everyone did
it's trump t-r-u-m-p same as the
building and he would hold the press
conferences and the players would say
fine up
i'm i'm leaving i'm going out to dinner
you can hear and uh to do the press
conference but
it's a lot of the same mo in 1984 that
uh
it would be 32 years later how close do
you think
the usfl or some of these teams came to
being absorbed by the nfl that that's
a great question because i mean the one
thing that became clear to me research
in this book is
we cannot underestimate the force and
you you know this better than
the force that is cable television and
this was right around the time that
these networks were realizing
you could charge the cable systems a
subscriber fee and totally change the
economics and by the way these networks
all need
programming and if trump i mean i think
single-handedly
trump did to the usfl like you know what
isaiah thomas did for the cba
in basketball i mean trump just wrecked
this league if they had
hung around and gotten a
cable tv deal whether it would have been
a competing league or whether it would
have had to have been absorbed
aba nba style the usfl
had they hung out a couple more years i
think they really could have made it
what stood out at the 84 olympics
um michael jordan no i think
i think what stood out was you had this
this boycott and everyone thought
this was the death of the olympics right
yeah you had terrorism in munich and
montreal was a financial disaster
a boycott in 80 and the soviets aren't
gonna
compete in 84 and it didn't matter and
for a variety of reasons peter yubroth
comes in for a lot of credit in this
book there was no
terrorism there was no drama we all
watched this it was a slow summer we all
got
big macs and fries when americans won
medals it was the highest
you know the most viewed program in
american tv history at the time
um peter you know we all love mary lou
retton and carl lewis and
jordan and knight who i see uh to your
left but um
peter uberoff was the the mvp of those
olympics
the stuff with jordan's interesting uh
going back to where he wanted to stay
for his senior year at north carolina
and and it almost felt like dean said
hey you're
going to the nba and the fact that bob
knight
it didn't take long for him to realize
that this is the greatest basketball
player talent-wise he had ever seen
trying to convince the blazers to take
michael jordan
and they said you know hey we got clyde
drexler and jim paxton
we have no room for michael jordan those
were great
those were great stories there great
nuggets
nice quote to to stu inman the gm of the
blazers who was uh
a friend of his and you're right the guy
said hey we don't need jordan we already
got a swing man we got this drexler guy
we have uh you know ironically enough we
have jim paxson
um and nice quote was
trust me take jordan play him at center
if you have to
you don't want to miss on this kid for
whatever his flaws were uh
give give bob knight credit for that one
toughest interview to get for the book
was who
uh the the interview that never happened
which was jordan
um he's tough and you know you i mean i
i
was saying this the other day you you go
back and you look at 1984
he is so cool and he's funny and he's a
prankster
and you know i mean i i certainly
understand how
fame can can wear you down but to me
it's a bit of a pity that he's
been a little reclusive because he was
great as a 20 year old great as a 21
year old and i think that the fame
monster sort of beat him up but uh
no people were great for this book and i
think it's because
david stern was a real resource and he
was basically saying
everyone remembers it right everyone
knows magic and bird and people have
these memories but
it's far enough away so i don't have to
worry about you know saying something i
shouldn't
so uh people were great when i got them
but
jordan full full disclosure jordan uh
declined my outreach
well and and i went through this
firsthand i was very lucky to do those
interviews after
he was winning championships but
he was going to be the number one
athlete these sports century
number one athlete and we couldn't get
him for an interview
and we were tr we were chasing michael
jordan down
to he was going to be the number one
athlete and then we like mike you're
going to be the number one athlete
everybody else has done an interview
here and we eventually got him i had to
go
to new york last minute to his hotel
set it up he came in from golfing and
he sat down and i don't know how long he
went and i don't even know how good it
was but we would have looked really bad
with the number one athlete and he
wouldn't sit down but
i i just think he gets to that point
where
what does he need to answer anymore but
if you had one question you knew
you were going to get an honest answer
from michael jordan
what would you have asked um i
wondered whether in 1984
he had a sense of where this was going
he was supremely confident
he knew about he understood the business
right away i mean david falk did not
have to convince him that
he needed his own signature shoe i i
think michael jordan
for as much as we talk about him i don't
think he's gotten enough credit for
really
changing the balance of power in terms
of athlete and management and i wonder
in 1984 if he was already on to this and
i think you know i mean
you and i know this right some athletes
are cut out for this and some athletes
say they are what they do
maybe they're just not that interesting
maybe they've been burned by the media i
mean
michael jordan go back and read about
you know
his quotes and the way he conducted
himself
you know his decision we've never
experienced a fraction of his fame i
certainly haven't but
this guy has peyton manning's sense of
humor and
barkley's instincts i mean at age 20 at
age 21
he was fantastic as as a character so
it's
it's a little it's a bit of a pity to me
that he's um so reclusive now because
he he had it in him to be this fake
figure who was
a lot more prominent in the call i mean
his call his decision
i hope he you know enjoys the golf but i
do think uh
he had it in him to be peyton manning or
barkley if he wanted to
yeah but i i look back differently on
jordan his mom made him go to portland
and meet with nike
uh you had the two different agents who
were going to represent him they kind of
said you get sam perkins and you get
michael jordan
sonny vaccaro is the one who deserves
the credit for michael jordan
being that because sonny said give him
all the money
get let's let's do a shoe based on a
player
that was unheard of because you had
magic and larry were doing converse and
as you point out in the book
converse didn't really invest in in
these individuals they just basically
gave you a check
sonny vaquero had the wisdom to say
we're going to create a shoe for michael
jordan that's that's the genius there
mike just went along for the ride
success has many fathers uh you know
george george raveling played a role i
mean i think some of this too
you know david falk is this tennis agent
and he has his boss donald dell
who's and funk is really kind of uh you
know it's like entourage i mean
you know david fox is really trying to
make a name for himself
and he seizes on jordan and says this
guy
is charismatic he's playing in a big
media market
he understands intuitively what i'm
trying to do
um so yeah i mean i think sonny gets
credit i think ravelin gets credit i
think
faulk gets credit but i think jordan got
it and jordan understood that there was
a lot more money on the table for an
athlete than
what his rookie contract with the bulls
was going to pay him
and jordan really you know jordan leaned
into the role right i mean he he did the
shoots and the limos and he did the
mars blackman and jordan understood
intuitively
that he wasn't going to make nearly as
much money from the bulls as he should
have but there were these other revenue
sources
and i think this is a real you know we
talk about sort of activism and then you
know
68 olympics and uh even more recently
kaepernick but i think
jordan understanding commerce is one of
these pivot points in sports history
that we're going to be talking about
i think that's true with jordan and
martina understanding
that speak up use your voice
i think those were the two the two
things that stood out so much
with the book so far that i've read and
uh you did a great job
it's uh it's it's a great read john and
uh i can't wait for the sequel 1985.
that that i'm sure you're working on
that right now right
trying to think uh before we get to we
get lakers and celtics again we got that
going for us but
i'm not sure it'll be quite as pivotal
oh no i appreciate it there's the
patrick ewing their lottery
uh the chicago bears i think
come on john do some research yeah
where's my agent no you're right
we have frozen uh frozen envelopes yeah
no this is uh no but sir i i appreciate
it and uh
i i like that uh you you you came across
that um
you you came across the anecdote with uh
with howard stern and isaac's turn but
seriously i mean you you caught this
cable wave
and um it's i i think okay
cable tv we uh it's propping up sports
and it's it's made figures like dan
patrick and i think um
it's gonna be interesting where we go
from here because
cable's really the story of sports in
the last 35 years
john thanks for joining us uh have a
great weekend and
we appreciate your time anytime thanks
dan that's
john wertheim he has written a great
book it's called
glory days the summer of 1984 90 days to
change sports
and culture forever now available online
wherever books are sold